[Music]
hello and welcome to sophie ridge on
sunday i'm not sophie i'm jane secker
and i'm sitting in for sophie this week
and
what a week it has been the prime
minister would probably have been
feeling pretty good
after helping kill off plans for the
european super league
but if he was hoping to spend the
weekend with his footer feet up in front
of the football
dominic cummings went and ruined his
plans on friday boris johnson's former
advisor published an
extraordinary blog denying being the
source of damaging leaks
saying secret plans to fund the
refurbishment of the downing street flat
were
unethical and possibly illegal and
accusing the prime minister of lacking
the integrity the country deserves
boris johnson has picked his battle the
big question now
is whether he'll live to regret it well
today we're going to be
talking about this story and more with
the international trade secretary liz
truss
jess phillips will shortly be on the
show to give the view from the labour
party
i've spoken to bill gates we discussed
covert vaccines foreign aid and when
things will get back to normal
and with less than a fortnight until the
scottish elections will be joined by two
party leaders in scotland
labour's and asawa will be on shortly
and we'll be speaking to the co-leader
of the scottish greens lorna slater
a little later on but first
labor has called for a full
investigation into the refurbishment of
the prime minister's downing street flat
after dominic cummings alleged that
boris johnson tried to get conservative
donors
to secretly pay for the works well we
can talk now
to labour's jess phillips great to talk
to you
this morning jess dominic cummings says
he thinks the prime minister has acted
illegally what's your view
the the truth of the matter is we don't
know the truth and we've got
scrapping between two very powerful men
who seem
more interested in who's lying about
what and who's leaking what than the
substantive
of the issue and that is that where the
contracts get given out by text messages
whether tax breaks get given out by text
messages
or whether the prime minister uses his
pals to get money to
have his flat down up the whether i back
dominic cummings view or boris johnson's
view what what we need is
a proper independent inquiry where it
isn't about two boys fighting and is
about
taxpayers in our country well in seeking
to get an answer to these questions is
the labour party going to ask for an
urgent question in parliament this week
i believe so i should very much imagine
that is the case as we return to
parliament
tomorrow um but whether we get the
answers because boris johnson will often
say one thing at the dispatch box if it
is even boris johnson or rishi sooner
or their their junior ministers who they
often send out to
to fight these battles for them whether
we actually get answers that then
meter out to any real transparency or
integrity
in the long run is is very difficult to
say so we need that urgent question we
need members of parliament to
to not think necessarily on party lines
but to be going after
all of us uh in parliament and all of us
in politics
uh integrity really really matters and
so we've got to ask those questions so
that people in the country can trust us
with their lives um but we need an
independent inquiry into this this needs
to be
properly root and branch not the prime
minister calling up his best friends in
their
different newspapers to have a pop-up
dominic comings and dominic cummings
touring rounds select committees or
writing blog posts
this we need to take this out of the
hands of the people who frankly have got
questions
to ask kirsten did say in the comments
uh this week that this is all about
sleesley sleeves but
the reality is that if labor were in
government and indeed when labour were
in government
you would have been lobbied you would
have faced very very similar accusations
well i i can't say that we would have
faced very similar accusations but what
the labour party is
asserting to do now would be a rule that
we all have to live by
and you know this isn't this is about
what is happening right now
and the contracts that have been given
out unfairly
it seems to businesses who can just get
in touch with the prime minister
no one's saying that people can't lobby
what shouldn't happen
is that people shouldn't be lobbying for
commercial gain for them and their mates
and that businesses in my constituency
should be able to lobby just as easily
to get contracts
to provide things that our country needs
as boris johnson's pals
but is it is it lobbying is it sleaze if
if what dyson was doing was
was an employer checking that that his
employees not him personally his
employees wouldn't be worse off
if they did something that they were
being asked to do by the government
that's not slaves that's just good
management isn't it well it's good
management that's not available to
anyone
in my constituency so during the
pandemic there were lots of
organizations in my constituency that
had to change there were lots of
individuals who had to change
tax arrangements for example people who
went back to work on bank shifts in the
nhs their tax brackets would have
changed
did any of them have the text access to
the prime minister
it's it whether you know it people do
things via text it has to be
open that that is what is happening and
so when my companies in birmingham
yardley
want to look at contracts for ppe or
ventilators which
many of them did i was given a generic
email address
for them to email which led to
absolutely nothing if only you know i
could have been in a whatsapp group
sending gifts to the prime minister um
peter mandelson pointed out this week
skewering the tories over sleeves which
obviously
labour is keen to do won't be enough to
win the 2024 election
it doesn't seem necessarily to be
cutting through at the moment if we look
at the latest
opinion poll it gives the conservatives
an 11 point lead
over labor despite all of these negative
stories
and boris johnson 41 approval rating
uh kierstalma 33 it's it's not great is
it that given all of these stories over
the last couple of weeks
labour are still lagging this far behind
the truth of the matter is i don't wish
to
skewer boris johnson for electoral gain
i wish to skewer him as a
taxpayer and somebody who i want to see
politics uh being made honest so that
people can trust
politicians and feel part of our system
again but you know what you're saying is
it it's a totally fair uh assessment of
the situation but we're in a pandemic
times and
and kiyosama has taken over the labour
party which was in a terrible position
in a very very difficult time where the
country is focused on
getting back to work getting to feel
healthy getting to feel like they can
cuddle their families
without being frightened of catching a
disease it's not a surprise that
opposition politics
is is difficult at this time but there's
there's a long time before uh the 2024
uh election and if i was to be
completely honest i don't want to skewer
boris johnson i want him to be better
i want him to be better for my
constituents i want him and his pearls
having a fallout and him these pills
giving each other contracts because
they're showing off to each other about
who's the most powerful
that's the thing i want to skewer here
it
it we saw this week kierstalma in front
of the cameras he had a really awkward
encounter in a pub
didn't he um where the landlord um
wanted to present him with some
information and then didn't want him in
the pub
at all um what did he think of of that
encounter and did you think that the
central exchange was the
central charge of what the landlord said
to mr salma was that
he's failed to hold the government to
account did do you feel that he's held
the government
feet to the fire enough yes i do think
he's
helped the government i i don't agree
with the the the thrust of what the
publican was saying
as if somehow lockdowns um
weren't necessary and in fact in the
papers today there's all sorts of things
about whether boris johnson uh terrible
things he's alleged to have said
maybe by dominic cummings who knows
about whether we have lockdowns
regardless of the amount of people who
died
there was a there was a simple thing
that had to be done we had to stop the
virus and i don't agree with the
republican on
on that but the idea that we haven't
held the government to account the
government has u-turned
many times throughout this crisis and
it's not fair to say that that isn't
because of the actions
of the likes of kirsten and his team the
sleaze uh conversation that we're having
is a partnership between very good uh
investigative journalism um and
rachel reeves on the labour front bench
has been saying this again and again
not just after these recent revelations
but for the last
year and and their feet are held to the
to the fire
but do you think i mean looking at how
he how kirstarma dealt with that you
know he
didn't interact he tried to walk away
and then he then then did interact it's
these kind of situations and election
campaigns are always a test of instinct
aren't they
um do you think he does have the right
instinct because if you look at sort of
the red wall seats and
and we look at you know the west
midlands area where you are the
conservatives are still doing better
shouldn't
labour have cut through by now i'm not
sure that if i don't know
kirsten has tried to lamp the landlord
that that would
be coming forward cutting through in the
middle i
suggest it maybe necessarily
to be honest i think he was incredibly
calm
in the face of a difficult situation
which is actually what i want from my
leaders
i don't want when they're faced with
challenge that they start ringing around
journalists to to have a pop of their
mates to say it isn't the difficult
times we should be focusing on it's
because seven says said seven so about
seven said
you know actually what i want to see
from my leader and what i think cuts
through from that exchange about kia
stammer is that he is a calm and safe
pair
of hands uh and all power to him
you know i'm not sure i would have been
so calm jess phillips
uh great to talk to you as always thanks
very much
now in just 11 days time scotland will
go to the polls in an election that
could have
huge ramifications for the future of the
united kingdom
the s p are seeking a majority labour's
fighting to regain second place from the
conservatives
neighbours leader in scotland anas sawa
joins us now
from glasgow thanks very much for
joining us um
labor is against independence in
scotland but this does seem to be yet
another election all about independence
doesn't scotland need greater powers in
order to fight its way
out of of covert and and manage its
recovery
i think there's certainly more need for
more devolution and i think people in
liverpool birmingham manchester cardiff
feel that just like they do in glasgow
where i'm sitting in other parts of
scotland so we can have a recovery that
works for everyone
but just on the first point jane it's
politicians that want to talk about
independence in this election campaign
it's
the conservatives and the snp who want
to make this election campaign
about which side you were on in a
referendum in 2014
but in actual fact didn't choose between
yes no leave and remain
the aftermath is not going to choose
between yes no even remain
this is a pandemic election not a normal
election and
i think too many of the other political
parties and other politicians forget
that 10
000 of our fellow citizens have lost
their lives and what this election must
be about and that's why i'm focusing on
what the labour party is focusing on
and what the next parliament has to be
about is that national recovery
so we can come through this most
difficult year that has been for all of
us in our lifetime
and actually build a stronger and fairer
nation and that's the case we'll be
making
in the last 11 years of this campaign
and beyond you maybe need to be speaking
to some of you for your labor candidates
because i've got a list here of ones
that
that have got quotes on independence and
the problem seems to be
that that the line coming from the
labour party is slightly confused and
woolly
uh dundee city west candidate mercedes
villalba in favor of another
another referendum now this is from just
january if we're not truly content with
the status quo haven't we better call
for a referendum to put our alternative
to the people
dundee east candidate own right again
this january
i wouldn't go as far as being
pro-independence and supporting yes
being a requirement but definitely be in
favor
of a second india ref would help bring
back voters to the party
uh lothian's candidate nick ward again
in january
this year um i do not think that
acknowledging the right to
self-determination and accepting that if
majority empowerment wants a second
referendum is a silly position so
there are a lot of people who will say
that the labour party doesn't have a
consistent
policy on this no it does jen because
what people are talking about there is
of course scotland has a right to choose
his own future but what we are all
united on in this election campaign our
manifesto makes it clear
is that we do not support independence
we don't support a referendum we believe
the next parliament should be focused
entirely
on delivering a national recovery and
pulling our country back together
not going back to those old arguments
not going back to the old divisions
and that is a case that only labor is
making in a serious way in this election
campaign and all our candidates
are unified on that but you might not
support independence but it does seem
that quite a lot of your candidates
support a referendum what are you not
worried that the very pro unionist
labour
party voters are going to vote
conservative this time around no no at
all
the challenge you have the clear fault
line in our election and the clear fault
line in scottish politics
is that we have 14 years of an snp
government seven years of nicholas
sergeant and first minister
and in that time there have been
catastrophic failures of government and
whenever there is a failure
the smp either says we would it wouldn't
have happened if we had independence
or worse still what they say is it might
have been bad
but look at that mob over there at least
we're not as bad as them pointing at the
tories
frankly scotland deserves better than
that and uk deserves better than that
and that's why this election campaign
has got to be about the next five years
and how we make
what has been a really really difficult
year how we come through and make a
fairer and stronger country
not going back to those arguments and
that's been the central part of my
leadership for eight weeks
in this job it's a central part of my
leadership for the last two weeks as we
lead up to that election
and i give the cast and guarantee to
every single person watching this
program
what i am putting forward is not a case
for half of the country that agree with
me on the constitution
i'm making a case for all of scotland
because i want
to come through this most difficult of
yours and have a recovery that works for
everyone
no matter what the traditional position
on the subject of recovery you have a
national recovery plan
offers various things promises various
things including 60 000 jobs for
recovery
um lot of bulk promises but questions
about how you would fund it the ifs
has had a look at your figures and said
you'd have to substantially increase
scottish taxes
and would need to double the unallocated
funding available to the scottish
government this year
to meet these manifesto promises are you
not writing checks that you're not in
cash
well we dispute that because there isn't
there is an overlap in terms of some of
the spending commitments we have made
so some of the spending commitments we
have made we've allocated the full
budget
but there are overlap in terms of
smaller amounts of budget that the smp
have allocated but we want to go further
than them
in terms of some projects i'll give you
one practical example of that and
we believe that there's going to be a
jobs crisis coming through this pandemic
and i don't want us to wait till after
the lockdown ends or after the virus
finally disappears for us to start
investing in that new jobs for the
future
so we have published the most ambitious
and largest job creation scheme
in the history of the scottish
parliament not 60 000 jobs
170 000 new jobs and i'm not shy about
the price tag it will cost 1.2
billion pounds but we have billions of
pounds of unallocated
recurring and non-recurring spend
available to us in the scottish budget
what are we waiting for we need to be
using that right now
to plan for the recovery start the
recovery right now so we do not have a
lost generation coming through this
pandemic
do you accept though that it will lead
to tax rises in scotland you said during
the
labor leadership campaign in scotland
that you'd bring forward more
radical tax policies than jeremy corbyn
so who in scotland is going to be paying
more tax under you well we've been
cleared i i support a more progressive
tax system but i believe we can use the
billions of pounds that are unallocated
alongside that i want to create a new
tax in scotland that targets those big
online giants like amazon who have done
such
a phenomenal success through these most
difficult times in terms of their
profits
let's tax companies like amazon
appropriately let's use that money to
invest in the high street to invest in
jobs so we can
what about individual taxpayers though
and then we have made a commitment that
we will not
look to increase personal taxation over
the course of the parliament
but if in the later part of the
parliament if we do have a deficit that
we need to meet with tax rises
we would only consider our tax rise in
the first instance of those earning over
150 000 pounds a year
and then those earning over a hundred
thousand pounds a year but our
presumption is against
personal income taxes so you're
confident that you can raise this 1.2
billion just for big business
no the 1.2 billion i think we already
have the 1.2 billion is already
available to us in terms of our first
year of spend
it's for the longer term as we're going
to year three four and five of the
parliament
that i think we can have a substantial
budget but if we have a gap in our
budget
only in that moment we look at personal
income tax rises for those at the very
very top
do you think you're tough enough to take
on nicola sturgeon um a lot of people
think that she's had a very good
covert outbreak and has done herself a
lot of favors um
if it comes down to it can you take her
on absolutely i can take her on and i'm
standing directly in her own
constituency
as a demonstration of that but look i i
don't want to take her on the way that
previous politicians want to take people
on which is
shouting at them getting angry at them i
think our politics deserves better than
that
i'm going to do it with honesty i'm
going to do it with humility
i'm going to do with empathy i'm going
to do it with unity and i want to spread
hope across the country
because that's the way we get the labour
party back on track but more importantly
that's the way we rebuild the country we
all love would you be interested in
forming another coalition with the lib
dems
no coalitions with anybody but i'm happy
to work with any individual political
party or any individual on
one off issues so for example i've
worked with every single political party
in the parliament
around tackling prejudice and hate in
all its forms my party worked with the
snp around the period products bill
and the protection of retail workers
bill i've worked with the liberal
democrats to get a public inquiry into
mental health services and more funding
for mental health services
i've worked with the greens around
reversing the sqa exams
fiasco from last year so individual
issues i'm happy to work with anyone
because if we can't come together at a
time of national crisis when can we come
together
so that's the challenge i lay down to
every other political party is
forget the divisions of the past forget
the old arguments
recognize that this is a pandemic
election where 10 000 of our fellow
citizens have lost their lives
and let our politics rise to the
occasion let's give scotland the
government and the opposition it
deserves and let's give it the
parliament it deserves so we can make
the best at what's been a really really
difficult situation
anasawa great to talk to you thanks a
lot for joining us thank you
a little earlier this week i spoke to
the microsoft co-founder bill gates
his organization the bill and melinda
gates foundation has so far committed
around 1.75 billion dollars to covert 19
relief efforts around the world
the foundation's also involved in the
access to covert tools
accelerator or act a which was set up to
support the development and distribution
of tests treatments and vaccines
the program is now on track to deliver 2
billion vaccine doses a year still a lot
of work to do though
and when i spoke to bill gates this week
i asked him to explain what act a does
and what it has achieved in that first
year
well as the pandemic struck a little
over a year ago
there was a realization that this was a
global problem
and that we needed to orchestrate
resources on a global basis
and so particularly the uk france and
germany
came together with other actors like the
who and our foundation and said okay
what are the vehicles we can use sepi
was there to do vaccine research agave
to buy vaccines global fund
for therapeutics including oxygen
and that's what act a is it's taking all
of that
additional resources and coordinating it
on a global basis
uh and so i'm you know it was super
valuable that we did that
uh of course you know because we didn't
prepare for this pandemic
uh nearly like we should have you know
we've been learning as we've been going
uh but you know i'd say the good news is
that
uh partly because of the act day efforts
partly because of u.s r d
money we have the vaccines and we can
see the
you know the end will come uh for this
pandemic
and what would you say the big success
has been in the 12 months
well the therapeutic area uh
has scientifically not yielded as much
as we would have liked
there was a trial in the uk the fair
trial that uh we helped fund that came
up with dexamethasone early on
as a late stage treatment and
fairly quickly people realized that
having oxygen was important
but we haven't had any dramatic
therapeutics unfortunately
the vaccine spaces is been
amazing not only did we get them uh
very rapidly now the volumes are getting
up
and we're using factories in india and
other places as a second source
so we're not just relying on the company
that invented the vaccine but for the
first time ever
transferring exactly that vaccine into
factories like it's serum or or by wee
uh to get the capacity up so that
you know we we want to vaccinate uh
certainly all the elderly in the world
and in most countries we want to get to
uh over 80 percent vaccination
and so that's you know kind of
mind-blowing particularly when we
we did very little to prepare in advance
and in terms of that
there's been some speculation that the
changing intellectual property rules
um and allowing these vaccines as you
say
the the the recipe for these vaccines to
be shared would be helpful
and do you think that would be helpful
no why not
well there's only so many vaccine
factories in the world
and people are very serious about the
safety of vaccines
and so moving something that had never
been done moving a vaccine from
say a uh a j j
factory into a factory in india that
it's novel it's only because of our
grants and our expertise that can happen
at all the
the thing that's holding things back in
this case is not intellectual property
there's not like some idle vaccine
factory
with regulatory approval that makes
magically safe vaccines
uh you know you've got to do the trials
on these things and
every manufacturing process has to be
looked at in a
in a very uh careful way
there's all sorts of issues around
intellectual property having to do with
medicines but not in terms of how
quickly
we've been able to ramp up the volume
here
you know i remember how shocked people
were when we said we were going to do
second sources in these developing
country factories uh you know that
that was a novel thing we got all the
rights from the vaccine companies they
didn't hold it back they were
participating i do a regular phone call
with the pharmaceutical ceos to make
sure that work is going at full speed
so it's it's not that that that's
slowing down slowing it down
more money would help more vaccines
physically
would help as well wouldn't it how hard
is it to get
the countries that have the vaccines and
obviously you know here in the uk we
have enough
to vaccinate our population five times
over
what are your feelings about that well
over the balance of the year
the u.s the uk and others will be able
to make sure that the vaccines are now
going
to the developing countries because many
of the vaccines worked
uh you know although we're looking at
you know some of the side effects now
and making sure we can treat those and
that they're very rare
that good news means that we will be
able to supply
others and the other good news is that
the actual death rate from this epidemic
in the poorest countries has actually
been quite low
and so the places where you know you
want to get everyone over 60 vaccinated
like south africa brazil
uh you know that that will become a
priority
uh just in the next you know three or
four months is when the us
will move into that uh excess uh
position
and take the exact day resources and use
them
uh to get those vaccination levels up as
fast as we possibly can
you know it is true that there's been
about a
four month gap that
depending on what happens with j j could
be over
six months typically in global health it
takes a decade between when a vaccine
comes into the rich world
uh and when it gets to the the poor
country so
in this emergency uh partly because of
the second source agreements
all the cooperation the government money
uh
where the uk france and germany actually
pulled act a together
with some other actors like the wh on
our foundation
that's made a difference because we
didn't practice
you know it's clear that understanding
variants and
understanding uh how quickly you can do
the regulatory stuff
you know when this comes up again we
could be a lot smarter
people didn't invest enough in this
risk uh forming sepi that the uk
and welcome and our foundation others it
was one of the few things
and it's only if you know a few percent
what should have been done
to really practice you know do
simulations
understand when that how quickly you
could get the diagnostics ready and so
you know i'm i i hope we keep
in mind that we do need to invest in
being ready for the next pandemic
but are you concerned about the
imbalance that there currently is
between some of the more developed
countries and the numbers of vaccines
they have
and the numbers of vaccines that are
available and are going to the less
developed countries
yes uh the reason our you know
foundation-funded gabi
which the uk is also a huge backrub is
to deal with these unbelievable health
inequities
and as i said in this case it's about a
four to six month delta
that's not fair uh but that's actually
doing very well
you know given that the the funding that
was provided the fact that the rich
countries have somewhat prioritized
themselves
uh you know that's not completely
surprising we don't have world
government that sits there and
you know ignores the the us r d money or
uk
r d money and overrides that because
the you know the fact of getting elderly
people vaccinated in the rich countries
which actually had
the pandemic worse than most of the
developing countries
that was a good thing the fact that now
we're vaccinating 30 year olds in
the uk and the us and we're not yet we
don't have all the 60 year olds in
brazil and south africa that's not fair
but uh you know within three or four
months
the vaccine allocation will be getting
to all the countries that have
uh the very severe epidemic and so act a
you know it doesn't get a perfect grade
but it does get a very high grade that
the second source deals did happen and
now
uh you know it's going we're going to
get to the point of equity
the us did not participate in the
multilateral activities the trump
administration stayed out of that that
made it harder
uh and put a lot of burden on france
germany and the uk and others
has it got easier since biden's arrived
yes it's changed dramatically
uh he unblocked the four billion that
the congress
uh had appropriated uh he rejoined the
who
uh and now you know the us and the uk
will be the first countries that'll have
the
excess vaccines and we'll you know use
these mechanisms
to get them out to where the death rate
is the highest
we've got the g7 coming up what are your
hopes for it
well i'm very pleased that the uk is
making
pandemic preparedness both finishing
this pandemic and
thinking through uh what happens next
uh it's a real priority
uh and in fact my wife melinda's
working with the prime minister on the
panel
uh that'll present what that template uh
for future preparedness looks like
because you know you've been talking
about the fear of a pandemic for a long
time and people haven't really listened
in a sense covered 19 has helped has
helped you and that's helped
people realize the importance of the
message that global health
is this crucial thing isn't it
i mean in a way do you think that that
covert 19 will will open up
the kind of organizations like yours to
more funding
to people being more open and receptive
to your message or
do you think we're all just we'll forget
about it once it goes away
well i'm worried uh that will forget
about it you know the ebola epidemic
uh was the time i thought people would
be interested and that's
uh you know when i i was out uh
talking about what we needed to do sepi
was created
uh which has helped with some of the r d
but that was only
you know say five percent of what it
would have meant to be
uh fully prepared the uk welcome and
ourselves were
among the backers of of that seppie
effort that has contributed
along with the uh you know country
specific r d money
i do think because trillions were lost
that this generation will remember this
and we will uh do simulations and we
will look at okay
can you make our mrna cheaper and have a
network of factories all over the world
not in every country but
enough so that the capacity could go up
you know five times faster than it did
this time
you did say um that you thought we'd be
getting back to normal by the end of
2022
completely back to normal i believe were
your words do you still think that are
you still hopeful of that time frame
yes i am uh you know there's still some
questions about
how broadly the j vaccine will get used
that
uh if that's accepted
you know would be very beneficial but
you know some of the rich countries
including the us and the uk even this
summer
will get to high vaccination levels and
that'll free up
so that we're getting vaccines out to
the entire world
uh in late 2021 and through 2022
and so we won't have eradicated
uh this disease but we'll be able to
bring it down to very small numbers
uh by the end of 2022.
here here in the uk um we haven't given
as many vaccines i suppose as you and
others would like to the developing
world
we're also expecting cuts to the foreign
aid spending what would you
like the uk government to do more of to
help
well the uk government uh you know was
great
in terms of realizing that vaccines were
important
supporting seppi supporting gabi uh this
act a thing which it's the anniversary
uh the prime minister was key to pulling
that together he's using the g7 meeting
you know for us uh the quicker the uk
can get its aid level back up to the
point seven percent
uh the better you know the needs there
are dramatic
uh uk aid the the voters there should be
very proud of the impact that that has
uh it's been the strongest proponent of
getting behind vaccines
and you know making sure we eradicate
polio
uh and with the cutbacks you know we we
won't be able to do as much
uh so i hope i hope that gets restored
because it is
is of critical importance
bill gates they're talking about covet
and his campaign
now earlier in the show jess phillips
told us that labour will ask for an
urgent question in parliament this week
about claims that boris johnson tried to
get a conservative donor
to pay for the refurbishment of his
downing street flat well let's talk more
about that now with the international
trade secretary liz truss
she joins us now uh good to talk to you
today liz do you know who paid for the
refurbishment of the prime minister's
flat
the prime minister met the cost of the
refurbishment of the flat
and that is very clear he's acted
completely in line with the rules
when did he meet those costs though
because there are allegations that a
donor paid a contractor
directly and that the boris johnson paid
him back which
would mean in the interim he effectively
had a loan
as i've said the prime minister met the
costs of the flat refurbishment
everything's been done in line with the
rules i think
now but but when did he meet the cost
that is that is key isn't it because if
if somebody you shouldn't be
throughout this process we and he have
complied completely with the rules
and i think this is a huge distraction
from what people actually care about
which is
how we're dealing with the pandemic
we've just had the news that 50
of people in britain have now been
vaccinated and of course as trade
secretary i'm working on how we build
our economy
after covid in particular by striking
new trade deals that are going to drive
jobs and growth across the united
kingdom we will
come on to all of those points but but
really on the flat it is quite key and a
lot of people are very interested in it
most people have to save up if they want
to redecorate their flat
it appears here that either a donor paid
a contractor directly or the
conservative party paid a contractor
directly
uh which was it the prime minister's met
the course of the flat
and as with all of these matters meeting
the cost of later dates
is the proper information has been has
been declared in the public domain
but as you can imagine as trade
secretary i'm spending i'm spending my
time focused on trade negotiations
not looking at flat refurbishments but
it hasn't been declared at all and
you know we're expecting it to appear in
the register of ministers interests but
the government
hasn't published that in fact the
ministerial code says it should be
published twice yearly but we only had
one last year in july
and the cabinet office has yet to
publish the latest installment which is
due at the end of 2020. so
it's actually not being declared and
it's only because dominic cummings made
these allegations and because
journalists have done some digging that
is now becoming clear
that boris johnson didn't pay for the
refurbishment out of his own pocket
initially initially he tried to get
somebody else to pay it and that is the
concern isn't it because if
a donor is paying for the refurbishment
of the flat uh he is then
uh has a loan from that donor or if the
conservative party's paying for it
that that is against the rules so it is
key isn't it to find out when he paid it
and to whom there was a statement made
to parliament at the end of last week
explaining the situation as i've said
the prime minister met the costs
of the flat refurbishment and you know
this is
obviously important that we declare
costs in line with
the rules and that's what the prime
minister has has done
but fundamentally what people care about
is dealing with the covered pandemic and
that is what the prime minister is
spending his time
doing you keep saying that he has
declared it but but but he hasn't we
we don't know when he paid this money
and it's the timing isn't it it's
crucial have you had a conversation with
him about it before you
you came on this morning to do these
round of media interviews
as i've said i know that the prime
minister has
acted within the rules that he has
covered the cost
of the flat refurbishment himself and i
think that this
issue is a massive distraction from what
we should be focused on which is
how we are recovering from the pandemic
the vaccination program
and the work we're doing to rebuild the
economy
um how do you know then that he's not
broken the rules you must have had a
conversation with him he must have
told you when he paid it then if you if
you're convinced that you know he hasn't
broken the rules whereas dominic
cummings
told him that what he was doing was
potentially illegal
well i have been assured that the rules
have been fully complied with
and i know who assured you of that met
the course of the flat refurbishment
but who assured you of that
i absolutely believe and trust that the
prime minister has done that
we're not getting any really clear on on
the timing are we
um it's part of the problem
i've just spent the last week
negotiating
a new trade deal with australia is going
to bring value to the british economy i
don't spend my time
getting involved in the details of the
flat refurbishment at number 10 and it's
very clear that the prime minister has
met the cost of that refurbishment
but but how do you know that he's
followed the rules then you know you you
said you've been assured that you
um you understand he's not broken the
rules you clearly have had a
conversation
about it we're just really trying to
find out exactly when
he paid
well all of the details will be
given out in line with the rules and
there are certain reporting procedures
and those procedures are being followed
any idea when we will find out
as i said they will be reported in line
with the reporting procedures
but he is very clear that he has met the
cost of the flat refurbishment
they're already late though aren't there
as i mentioned to you about the
ministerial code
you know they should have been declared
months ago
so they're not they're not being
declared on time
these costs have been outlined in line
with the ministerial code
of course the civil service is
responsible and
working with the prime minister to make
sure those things happen
but where have they been declared in the
ministerial code they haven't
as i've said these items are declared in
line with the ministry or code
the civil service make sure that happens
the prime minister has met the costs
and i'm very surprised that you're using
if they were interviewed
to ask the same question again and again
well it's because you're not answering
if they were declared in the ministerial
code we would have it and
it would be in the public domain the
point is that it should have been
declared in the ministerial
there was a statement there was a there
was a statement made to parliament on
precisely this subject at the end of
last week but that isn't the ministerial
code
what people want to know is that in line
with the rules the prime minister has
met the cost of
this refurbishment that has happened
all the costs will be declared in line
with the rules
and that as far as i'm concerned
completely answers that question
okay it's part of the problem that we
don't have an independent advisor on
ministerial standards
um so alex allen quit in november didn't
he over the pretty patel bullying
and the post has been vacant ever since
uh sunday telegraph today reporting that
maybe a wobble from the person
who is meant to be replacing them don't
don't we need somebody holding this
government to greater scrutiny
of course it's important that that role
is appointed
so when when are we going to get
somebody in the role
well i understand that is about to
happen shortly
shortly any any clearer on timing with
that
i don't have any more details for you
i'm afraid on that
okay um other things that dominic
cummings mentioned in his blog last week
was about the lockdown leak
uh the so-called chatty rat incident uh
which is uh all about who and what uh
leaked stories about the the second
covert lockdown and
the central allegation is that the prime
minister tried to halt a leak inquiry to
protect the friend of his partner
is the prime minister more worried about
his girlfriend's
friends than perhaps he is about the
safety of the country under covert
well the leak inquiry is ongoing and of
course
i hope that it finds who the
individual was who conducted this leak
because it's
very very unhelpful when confidential
information is
leaked from the government but why do
you think the prime minister it seems
tried to stop this leak inquiry then
as i've said before i mean this is title
tattle that's being
uh promoted and i don't think it really
addresses the key
issues that people in britain care about
i mean
others would say it's actually a really
serious allegation if we were trying to
find out
the timings of of lockdowns and what the
motivation was
because it could potentially have saved
many many lives
um but perhaps the most damning thing
that dominic cummings
said last week it is sad to see the
prime minister and his office fall so
far below the standards of competence
and integrity
that the country deserves i mean the
prime minister's been accused of
hiding donations cancelling inquiries to
protect friends
isn't dominic cummings right that he has
fallen below the standards of integrity
we need in a prime minister
well the prime minister and i work with
him very closely has been working flat
out to make sure we deal with this
terrible pandemic that we roll out the
vaccine program which has been
incredibly successful we've got half of
the people
in the united kingdom vaccinated now
and to make sure we deal with the crisis
and we also
work to build the economy back we work
to promote jobs and growth across
britain and
that is what people care about and you
know these
allegations and title tasks really are a
distraction from that key job and i know
the prime minister
is spending his time on what's important
which is dealing with the coverage
crisis
but working flat out is is different to
to not having integrity isn't it and
dominic grieve
yesterday said that he was a vacuum of
integrity johnny mercer said this week
it's the most distrustful awful
environment
it's rather windy out here
you're doing ever so well battling
against the elements i'll i'll just ask
you that again
well done for not getting hit on the
head um
i'll just re-ask that dominic grieve
said that that the prime minister's
vacuum of integrity johnny mercer has
said
uh in that government almost nobody
tells the truth
um i don't think anyone can really get
on the high horse about trust and ethics
all the rest of it politics because as
far as i'm concerned
most of it is a bit of a cesspit now
these are quotes from conservatives
they're not from the opposition
about your leader are they wrong
it's it's completely wrong the prime
minister
who i work very closely with has
consistently
through this crisis acted in the best
interest of the country
you know we've had a huge success in
this vaccination program which thanks to
the decision of the prime minister and
my colleagues across government we're
now working hard to rebuild
the economy and these noises off
are simply not helpful they're not
contributing
to a positive future and they don't
reflect
what is actually going on in downing
street
well potentially not a positive feature
for boris johnson i mean i mean
it's it's odd isn't it because he does
appear to be a really sort of affable
evoncular chap when he's in front of the
tv cameras
but the picture that's emerging from
those who work closely with him
seems really very different um the
journalist eddie mayer once rather
boldly accused the prime minister of
being in his words a nasty piece of work
was that was there a grain of truth in
that
i work very closely with the prime
minister he is doing a fantastic job
in very difficult circumstances and i
think you can see the result of that in
the success of the vaccine program
what we're doing to rebuild the economy
what we're doing in trade we've just
recently
agreed with the australians that we are
striking this trade deal which is going
to bring thousands of jobs across the
united kingdom
and that is what the british people are
focused on and that is why
he has such support across the country i
did promise we would come on to trade
and you brought it up again then of
course as you say you've had talks this
week with dan to hand
the trade minister um slightly
embarrassing
leak uh from a source close to you
earlier in the week saying that you plan
to sit him down in an uncomfortable
chair
so he had to deal with you directly for
nine hours he needs to show he can
play it at your level did he play at
your level
well that's a complete load of nonsense
uh what appeared in the press the fact
is that
dan and i have a very positive
relationship we had really positive
talks over the last two days
we're now within a glimpse of striking
our first
post-brexit trade deal which is
negotiated from scratch
and i'm looking forward to agreeing that
in principle
in the next few weeks and this will
bring huge benefits to the british
economy whether it's the whiskey
industry
the car industry the financial services
industry
and it also opens up huge opportunities
for us in the asia pacific market
one of the fastest growing parts of the
world and i'm looking forward to
building that even further is australian
wine going to become a little bit
cheaper
well that is one of the many benefits
that there will be from the australia
trade deal
okay um covered you mentioned as well
um we've seen some really distressing
scenes from india over the last couple
of days haven't we
um and there is obviously great concern
about the so-called indian variant there
are now
according to phe 132 cases
of that variant in the uk three that
weren't linked to travel from india
how worried are you about this
well the situation in india is extremely
worrying i had a call last week with my
indian counterpart we're working to do
what we can to support
the indian government particularly in
areas like oxygen we're putting together
a package of support but it is
a deeply concerning situation and my
thoughts and prayers go out to the
people of india
is there any evidence that the indian
variant can
escape vaccine protection
there is no evidence of that at this
stage but of course we're constantly
monitoring
uh the variants and the impact they have
on the vaccination program
to make sure we're able to do with deal
with that
but as i said my thoughts are really
with the indian population and we are
doing all we can to help
india deal with the terrible tragedy
that is happening in their country
is there a possibility that it could
slow down the easing of the lockdown
here in the uk
if these figures start going up here
we're still on track with our road map
we're constantly monitoring to make sure
that we're able to deal
with any new variants that emerge and
make sure our vaccination program
always works to be able to do that
there are some people who've pointed out
that it took several days for travel
from india to the uk to actually
stop would you like to have seen it
happen a bit quicker
well when we did announce uh the
travel ban we do need to make sure that
that can be operationalized at the
borders
so that was important to have that gap
to be able to get the borders
arrangements in place okay
liz trust uh thanks very much for
talking to us today well done for
avoiding the
thank you camera thank you very much all
right thank you
before we move on a reminder to check
out the sophie ridge on sunday podcast
we record it straight after the show and
it features the best bits of the
interviews plus some extra analysis
you can find it on the sky news app or
wherever you get your podcasts
from lunchtime today now earlier in the
show we heard from
excuse me the leader of the labour party
in scotland and as we count down to
those crucial elections on may the 6th
we're now joined by
another scottish party leader the green
party's
lorna slater uh thank you very much for
joining us lorna
um you're a pro-independence party
um the polls though have shown a bit of
a slide in support for independence
over the last few days uh noes now
saying 53
yes 47 uh have you backed the wrong
horse here
the important part of this election and
what our manifesto talks about
is the recovery from the pandemic that's
the context that we're all living in
we are we desperately need a fair and
green recovery from the pandemic
creation of jobs upgrading of scotland's
homes and of course tackling the climate
crisis
what we're looking at in this election
is
the right of the scottish people to make
the decision about who makes those
decisions
so what we're looking at is asking for a
referendum
and given that we have had a
pro-independence majority
in parliament all this while and we
expect with the help of the scottish
greens
to have a pro-independence majority in
the next parliament as well
we think the people of scotland have the
right to decide who's going to be making
decisions about their recovery
is it the brexiteer tories in london or
is it a government in scotland
that we've actually elected but isn't it
a distraction to be arguing about all
this because as you say there is so much
that that needs to be done after covid
um you know
it doesn't make sense to to use
political time
to go over this debate when there was
already a referendum we were told it was
a once in a generation event
democracy is a process of governing by
consent and as with any discussion on
consent
you need to check in regularly to see
whether people are still happy with the
direction of travel
it's very important to hold governments
to account and i think that a lot of
people in scotland
have deep concerns about the direction
of travel of the uk
the home office making life more
dangerous and
unpleasant for refugees cutting off
you know positive uh relationships with
the eu we seem to be alienating our
nearest neighbors we're
you know making fool of ourselves on the
international stage by calling
client people who concerned about the
climate crisis bunny huggers
the direction of travel at the uk is
deeply concerning and when boris johnson
thinks a recovery means
buying more nuclear weapons while at the
same time cutting public services
and seeing that nurses only get a one
percent pay rise i think it's very
reasonable
to ask the people of scotland do you
want to go along with this or do you
think we can do something better
do we think we can invest in a more
progressive
in a fairer more welcoming scotland is
that the kind of country you want to
live in
well in terms of of of being more
progressive one of the things that the
green party's embraced is something
called the yogyakarta
uh principles why has the green party
decided to support these they have no
standing in international law
and they've not been adopted
internationally in any treaty it's it's
about
trans rights isn't it and it's about
ensuring that the people
are not discriminated against because of
their gender
but there are a lot of people who have
many reservations about these principles
in particular
the scottish green party like green
parties all around the world is based
upon four principles
sustainability equality radical local
democracy
and we need to we need to make sure that
all humans have
fair human rights and that is a core
part of what we believe in
we do not believe that trans rights are
counter to women's rights all humans
have the same human rights
so of course uh when we when trans
people gain human rights or we make sure
that their human rights are respected we
don't take away the rights from anyone
else
absolutely a lot of women are concerned
that if you remove
sex from from a lot of documentation
that jeopardizes the provision of single
sex spaces
that women have had to fight to to to
receive and
principle 31 of of the yogyakar yata
principle
specifically says ensure that official
identity documents only include personal
information that's relevant reasonable
and necessary
and the registration of sex and gender
of a person identity documents such as
birth certificates
um passports etc i mean do you think
people in scotland
really don't want the sex of their child
recorded on a birth certificate
because because that is relevant to
that changing the we can get into the
technical detail of the interpretation
of that
exact bit of wording in that document
well your manifesto says
enshrine the yogyata principles in scots
law
we are not talking about removing the
sex from a birth certificate that is
absolutely not what we're talking about
that law is meant to refer to identity
documents in countries where
your identity document has to have your
sex or gender on it so that you can
um access your civil rights we don't
have identity papers like that in
scotland
you don't have to use your birth
certificate to access civil rights
it is it's sort of one of those sort of
technical details but
we are absolutely not talking about
removing sex
from birth certificates that is not what
we're proposing at all
is the manifesto wrong then because it
does say that it will enshrine
the yogyakarta principles into scots law
so the way you've interpreted that line
of that particular
that you read out there is not how we
would interpret that that is about
having the correct
gender on your documentation and that
means people should absolutely
be able to identify their gender as they
do already on their passport
on their driver's license we're not
proposing to change that that's already
in law you can change the gender on your
passport or your driver's license to
make it match your self-identified
gender
we already have that in the uk we
already have the gender recognition act
that says that you know if you follow
the process
to get a gender recognition certificate
you can then also change the gender on
your birth certificate
that is what is in law and that was is
what we would like to see
kept the only change we would like to
see to that is the change to the gender
recognition act to make that process a
little bit more humane to make it a
little bit more straightforward
at the moment it's very medicalized it's
very hostile
it means that a lot of people who would
really like to change their
documentation to make sure it's correct
don't don't do so because the process is
so unpleasant it's a very
very small change that we're wanting so
what insurance can you
so what reassurance can you give to
women in scotland that that under a
green party leadership
the provision of single-sex services
won't be
implica implemented and that for example
if a woman goes to a rape center
she won't necessarily have to be
examined by somebody who was born a man
the scottish greens follow the advice of
women's groups in scotland
engender scotland rape crisis scotland
scotland's
all these charities and campaigns that
work for women's rights
we follow their guidance and their
advice and this is what we always do we
follow
the advice of experts and women's groups
we know that those
wh what you fear there isn't isn't
what's going to happen
there is no concern about
women not giving consent for being
medically examined it's an absolute
with one of these whistle uh dog whistle
things
against trans right this sort of
terrible fear that a traumatized woman
would be
re-traumatized by a rape crisis center
that is not what rape crisis centers are
there for rape crisis centers are there
to support
women and trans people and anybody who's
been traumatized
in the circumstances but we also have to
respect the human rights of people who
work
in those centers and who people who give
those support services
so the we absolutely
are you know women would have to women
do absolutely have the right to consent
um you know you need to have consent
before you can medically examine someone
there isn't a question around allowing
women to be unsafe and traumatized by
you know when they
at access rate crisis uh centers we
always follow the advice of rape crisis
scholars and then gender and other
women's groups
to make sure that women are properly
protected and that means trans women as
well
because trans women also need to be able
to access these services safely
okay lorna slater from the green party
in scotland interesting to talk to you
this morning thank you very much
well that's it for the main show but
don't go anywhere after the break we'll
be
going over everything that we've learned
in sophie ridge the take
and our deputy political editor sam
coats also has some interesting polling
about whether people think
boris johnson is corrupt and whether or
not they care
straight after this break
[Music]
you